yeah hello welcome to this video
round four of the London candidates
tournament after one day off on Monday
they're back playing the fourth round
Aronian leading before this round with
+2 followed by Sweden and Rosen with +1
so let's see what happens today's Villa
playing black against aronia and that's
a surprise with luck going for the
Queens gambit accepted and on top of all
that is playing a six which is a
sideline it's um really an openness
introduced by your champion Alekhine or
Yaffe and trying hard to pronounce that
and real surprised as mentions Villa
it's not a regular predict practitioner
of the Queens gambit of not sure if he
has ever played it but suger seems to be
excellently prepared for this tournament
and he's got a couple of surprises in
his back as it seems okay III and b5
this looks a bit weird I'm sure because
to to most are to some of the spectators
he because you're not supposed to cover
this pawn in the Queen's Gambit take it
and hold it but there are lines like
this where this is some in fact a viable
strategy I only need to return it at the
right moment a form we should to be
seven and b3 so white is attacking the
the pawns and now black is returning the
pawn instantly takes
and their widest got the pawn back so
what has happened yeah
we are from an early opening year of the
queenside like is
quickly setting up his his formation
yeah what I find that really remarkable
is the time spent here Villa only spent
ten minutes and Aronian only 20 so he's
playing quickly even after being
surprised I'm pretty sure that his six
must have come as a surprise to him or
this whole line but it simply didn't
show on the clock he really seems to
make make an effort at not getting into
time trouble SS Carlton it's a very
practical decision
you see both players around and Cardinal
constantly being ahead of the clock here
it's okay cousin Aronian is ten minutes
short compared to sweet levity basically
blitz the hardest moves against oh sweet
lamb obviously very well prepared and
look but there's a pawn hanging on a6
and Aronian grabbed it after sub
continuation so sweet Allah had this
pawn sacrifice figured out before and we
see that he's getting very quickly some
pressure on the Queen side not yeah a
bit similar to the bank oh and there are
so much pressure on the Queen side that
you will get back the apron and this
frankly means that the whole position
gets gets traded down
yeah and draw a grid they need to make
30 moves on until they can agree to a
draw
yeah very dull game but it's not great
for the spectators I understand and I
would have liked to see some fireworks
as well but just from her from from a
tournament point of view distance
excellent force wiggler he basically got
a draw with black against one of the big
guys without probably thinking too much
I mean he had all this prepared and just
reap this reward for working hard at
home this is what sometimes people don't
appreciate they say okay this is all
done at home and so on but you actually
put have to put in the hours to figure
all this out of course the computers is
calculating for for those guys but you
need to look at all the stuff there
these computers are are calculating and
pick out the really interesting things
and actually yeah memorize them and put
them into your head it's it's really
it's it's tough work and this is really
important I guess for swimmer to get
this easy drunk he can try to push with
white next round and then this is how
you get your points and this is events
so a good good to draw I guess Aronian
um I was simply surprised and didn't get
anything so wrap it up make it wrong and
in the next game which is also not that
interesting in comparison we have two
really interesting games so here's to
two not so great and two really really
interesting games a job of crumbling
here and let's see we get an insole and
the rubenstein Cromley come placed more
than one line in this opening but he
decided to go for the cap of variation
with b6 which is some
a very reliable way of course for black
to to play this on he's played this with
both colors also with white for instance
he won one very important game in the
World Championship match 2000 against
Kasparov on the white side of this
position maybe it is a bad omen living
from Kasparov place the cup of variation
as black okay so we am I put some more
moves on the board this has been played
really really often yeah not G fall it's
an interesting motif here threatening
mate on h2 or let's say take on a3 and
then the made on h2 and this provokes
white to exchange those bishops and
frankly speaking I really don't
understand to a job was preparation yeah
I mean it's really hard sometimes to
understand I'm not it's not like I'm I'm
in a position to to criticize those
players much they are so immensely
strong but I really don't understand
what she is doing in the preparation if
you play like this year you know that
kramnik is going to play the nihms oh
and you know that this is a very very
possible setup that that will come up
and then he's spending time and here
with a c8 well what is he doing like
reinventing the theory and right here
that's it it's clear that black has
absolutely no problems at all I'm not
quite sure what he's doing I mean if you
want to try to win some games I bet you
better try with white and this is
basically giving a half a point away or
at least not trying at all to get a win
so it's simply the problem is how do you
make any progress what is white able to
do in this position there on you you
have to look at two things in a position
other
the first thing is pawn breaks well
porn-wise there's not much to do what
can go point to a5 and exchange on v6
this will make like very marginal
weakness on v6 this is basically the
only pawn move that you are going to do
d5 is is unlikely to happen as it is so
well protected c5 gives up the d5 square
so what pawns white cannot do much then
you've got please play the other thing
to try well it's not a position for
rooks exactly and white cuts could try
to get Knight to d6 or something but how
on earth are you going to manage that
this basically means this is a nothing
position and it simply didn't happen
much I mean look at this got a couple of
exchanges yeah as mentioned white
managed to get rid of his a pawn but
that's simply not not happening much
yeah it's quite funny this rook on d5
what never could take because he won was
singing but frankly there's not not
happening anything in this position and
I didn't even see what happened
afterward 40 I guess they didn't they
didn't do do something too exciting yeah
no they repeated Musa so I'm simply a
kind of game where white didn't try it
all to get some advantage may be
confused to move forward or anything and
it was simply yeah nothing game and in a
way not not easy probably to play it's
the tension if you don't want to lose
and so on yeah but it's it wasn't much
to do to come comment upon here um okay
so two games left and
I'm going to start with thousand on and
Scooby shocked thousand playing one
eform not a see form like dance kramnik
where there was this quick draw and we
got a boolean defense unsurprisingly
we shall play in this okay but I mean he
played it before but it's not his main
weapon against before okay thousand I
placed III he usually does that he
doesn't play the endgame the Berlin Wall
and game Bishop c5 c3 castles castles
yeah white cannot win a pawn like that
because d5 is really dangerous for white
opening up the position castles d6 yeah
and now I'm white as the choice can take
and he can withdraw the bishop and
Carter decided to play it a very simple
fashion just taking and now in the long
run play on the pawn structure p89 to d2
and now this is an interesting moment
group now decides to change the pawn
structure with d5 after he takes d5 yeah
black needs to take with the Queen
otherwise the five is just falling so
something like this is just a pawn down
for nothing so he needed to take with
the Queen and now we have an imbalance
in this position of course blacks got
two bishops and he's got yeah space
black has gotten at the moment a slight
space advantage but the problem the
problems in this position is got
slightly we keep on it's a bit pressure
on this point and of course in the long
run here the Queen side the pawns are a
weakness so
it's an interesting position what I find
interesting is how quickly now
Carlton activates his position queen
bees Knight to b3 Bishop f8 all the way
back
I guess he he didn't want to allow
something like this that the bishops are
immediately exchanged him
and now the interesting move c4 this is
yeah move justified basically by by
concrete calculation the Queen needs to
go to the sixth otherwise the bone is
gone so 26 and Bishop III now what is
threatening Bishop c5 and this is a
serious threat of black goes for some
nothing move dense Bishop c5 and next
move white will capture a fight with ya
with a win basically winning a central
pawn for nothing so this is really a
threat so black must play 97 and its
really remarkable with three moves White
has activated his position enormously
and now before coming here black has got
two Prince very very fundamental choice
he went for a four which i think is is
it it's okay but he also could have
taken on default this however after
Queen D for Queen d4 Knight takes leads
to an end game where those weaknesses
can be can be tricky a possible
continuation here is for example C 596
group e6 and Knight to a5 and it's
really difficult for black to yet to
untangle the pieces can go here try
something like this but I think it's
it's slightly annoying this position and
I can perfectly understand that we
should didn't want to play this against
cards and he played before which is
perfectly alright I think but the
continuation is maybe a problem that he
played put a 5 intending a 4 and Carlton
just put a stop to that a 4
which also means that a five is a
possible on yeah point we'll attack him
the night on v3 is already putting some
pressure on this bond here in fact I
think maybe Gousha come played them to
play the move that leads him into
trouble and it's a it's easy for me to
say because I saw the the the postgame
interview with Carlton where he was
asked and what do you think what led to
two blacks trouble and he said at this
point he was very delighted to see the
move f5 this is what Grisha played
instead um there is the move Queen to g6
which I think Carlton didn't mentioned I
try to figure out myself what else
should black play and Queen g6 is a good
move here the ideas some that um you
want to activate your pieces Knight f6
and maybe then initiate this kind of
threat um this is some I guess the move
that black should go for with probably
mutual mutual chances f5 as mentioned
was played and now I'm countin as I said
the interview I get what I want
c5 attacking the Queen and I think here
was the last the last point of the game
where black could maybe put up a real
fight it's really getting quickly
downhill it's it's amazing he played the
Queen to g6 now one move to later here
if you want here I think I think still
Queen e6 was an interesting way to try
just for a moment covering this square
so that night c4 immediately is not
possible and the idea is to quickly get
the Knight to d5
even if why the text the porn you can
consider to to sacrifice the spawn it's
not a very strong pawn anyway something
like this I haven't worked this out in
detail but this is an idea for example
something to get get active play after
Queen g6 the problem is white girls not
c4 and now you have big problems even to
get in this move because that's 95 also
in the mix now so why just got to c4 so
much quicker in comparison and I think
now it's it's almost too late the scary
thing is that you say it's too late and
ok yeah you know that Magnus hardly lets
anything slip and it's really amazing
from now on it's basically gone like
never gets a chance to to get back in
the game and he's doing this was very
nice simple but strong moves Knight f6
here for example white could just take
on a 5 but this maybe gives black some
chances to at least complicate metals
let's say F 4 this is not really great
but just have a look something like this
black could try and at least this Bishop
is activated in in some way what he
played it just played Bishop afro and
this is strong Black has got all those
weaknesses and something of those
weaknesses some of those weaknesses will
fall and this way there's simply no F
forms this is just stopped and after
Knight here 22 simple but very strong
just covering the bishop and next move
you will take a 5 this is some just just
very nicely played to keep the counter
play at me
we should be six now and now it's the
point to to look at the clock three
sugars down to four minutes is really
one of those time trouble
time travel addict guys and there's no
increment job you need to remember that
so it needs to make nineteen moves now
in four minutes which is in blips terms
not so much but you need to play a good
moves as well and cards and look at this
he's got more than one hour sixteen left
so he really played this this quickly
okay now we can take a five and black
playbook be age and this intense some
some tricks ninety-five Queen f6 here's
one trick if you are a bit too too quick
here and play Bishop g5 Black has got
the very funny moves III cutting this
connection between the two pieces if you
take on f6 black takes here attacking of
the rope and he wins wins material just
really bad London what white needs to do
is we should be three and then F for
tendus this Bishop is trapped funny
enough and the positional gets gets
really messy you don't want that Bishop
g5 is a really big mistake but just drop
it back really simple simple and strong
keeps the bishop
out of harm's way and what is like I'm
supposed to do now it's really not easy
to give them any advice and what's funny
though is the computer suggestion which
is completely ridiculous the best move
according to to even to Houdini you
don't really need to get to a bad engine
is Queen h6 mathematically the best move
but justice of course something which a
human being never would consider as this
is
just an automatic win for white getting
queens off and completely ruining
ruining your York inside pawn structure
even so this is complete nonsense
well goosh agree shocker took on a five
try for some desperate cover to play
queen eight five rugby - so he
sacrificed an exchange to try to stay up
some trouble but it didn't materialize
also due to very good defense
Ruby one look at - you don't want to
exchange and now queen essex it's not
terribly difficult but still strong he
wants to go rocky - exchanging the rook
and covering the second-ranked this is
relevant immediately III takes Queen g5
and black is threatening checkmate and
now you have rocky - this was the whole
idea so I'm very nicely defended if
Knight c3 which at first looks a bit bit
dangerous walking here can take him
Quinn takes and this is just holding for
White's nothing nothing happening with
him so he went 93 relatively
best chance and now Knight f3 this was
the last important move that really
really wins the game the Queen a subject
needs to go back and now you can simply
take on a2 and with rook be to cover G 2
so this some pretty much decided the
issue the thing is like dropped back
here the thing is black is attacking
with Queen and two minor pieces while
the f8 bishop is basically dead and what
is y doing he's defending with two minor
pieces and the Queen but his colleagues
sure look basically so this attack can
never really do too
thing Bishop to g5 and now the queen
drop back attacking III so with all
forces some back near the king the tech
is is easily diffused yeah a look-see to
Auntie agree shocker resigned if you
look at the clocks it's looking like he
lost some time but it's not the case he
really AM he meant he still managed to
resign the game
he's an exchange down and it's
completely hopeless there's also the the
a porn so I'm certainly okay to resign
looked at Calvin really used some time
at the end he really wanted to make sure
to wrap this game up in in convincing
their fashion and I think he really
managed so important when he is now even
with Aronian with plus two after four
rounds and one thing I watched him with
interview with kramnik I think after
round one all right - I'm not sure why
he stated that he's expecting that a +4
score would be enough to win it outright
the tournament and maybe even plus three
would be good enough for for tiebreaks
and well I beg to differ
I think there will be a nice plus five
needed to do to win this maybe maybe
even more cars is already n plus two and
the way he's playing um I don't know and
Aronian is also quite quite in good
shape so I think there's at least plus
four plus five needed to to win this
event okay so but there's still one game
left and this is Gelfand even shock I
don't really want to go so much into
into the opening here only mentioning
that Iran shook is going for the chicken
defense which somehow I had
I don't know and when I saw this I mean
he lost two games now and he's one of
those people if something's going wrong
there's the chance of a total meltdown
and that she Goran is really a little
bit of a dubious opening it's not not
like completely wrong or bad or
something but it's a bit shaky and I
don't know I had a bad feeling when I
saw this but it it led to interesting
play let's let's put it this way
I mean Gavin played the relatively quiet
set up against us but a good set up
something that can be recommended if you
don't want to go into something sharp so
we have a rather typical position for
this opening the black has surrendered
the bishop pair and has got some active
nights and no return so both sides can
serve long 94 so I put this on the board
rather quickly it's pretty much logical
yeah here an interesting way to play
Gavin played f4 really strange looking
move but first you yeah you wonder what
was he thinking probably his intention
is to reroute the bishop at some point
and then play f3 for very very long term
otherwise it looks really strange to put
the bishop on edge to him and he's aware
that this is a bad piece but he wants to
use it later okay m5 by a bunch of
making sure that the F chord is not
moving
now g5 not a five rook c8
so 3d tuna so here here it comes
this should be for Queen III and here
even shocked really went for some some
amazing concept which is just showing
that okay is may be very bad at time
management in this tournament but she
still
a real genius at the board he played c5
now okay
nothing spectacular at first but have a
look takes takes and now go from play d4
and well what it's black supposed to do
if you move the knight use Judas lose a
piece right this is easy what happens if
you take on e4
there's 90 for the rook is hanging and
if through boosters f5 and black is
completely exploding so on who yeah what
about black here is he lost
no okay rook c8 and this was all planned
with c5 he just lets this piece hang and
wipe now of course could have taken this
this piece what is happening after the
capture takes rook takes and now the
queen is saying this didn't happen is
just a possible line the queen is saying
where as it's supposed to go it only has
got two squares III III and f3 Queen III
is relatively easy to dismiss
there's not c4 and you cannot take this
piece because here black wins very
easily and after Queen move let's say
here there's not d2 coming and this is a
disaster black us is just winning out
right here with this active pieces so
Queenie three years just not not on so
Queen f3 what's happening here and the
amazing thing is have a look takes
takes
and we have ever made to come this is
with Queen III but Queen f3 this is
three of the real deal but you have seen
an important motif here
what is blacks supposed to do here takes
takes and now the amazing point black
can SEC the Queen and play not see form
and now we have the threat Queen D
lightly to check King a1 and route c1
mate
so this the same idea that we saw before
is on again and it's white smooth have a
look there's no way to prevent it this
except for giving up the Queen that's
also 92 threatening winning the Queen
so I test aloof it just needs to do
something like this Queen moves 92 and
return the Queen for minor piece so that
we have this kind of endgame on the
board which is probably roughly equal
you could analyze this further but it's
it's roughly equal yeah this is one of
the the most amazing lines that I saw
recently this position where black is
down yeah rook for Queen and Bishop
amazing and it's still a perfectly a
ride for black so on yeah taking on d5
would have led to this end game the
funny thing is white probably needs to
do that what he did because black is
also threatening from something see Roxy
2 and so on
he played rook c1 and this led to big
trouble Knight c4 intending 92 and yeah
here white has no alternative he needs
two seconds he for this exchange and
then now take on d5 and here the problem
is even Chuck's clock again
his his on three minutes and 20 seconds
here and in this position black can
could have won the game with Roxy - this
would have been very strong one point
being if white tries to to kick the
bishop here with a three black can can
it can sacrifice this as this is leading
to win with rook to the sea three one
one of the big points but this is easy
to to point out for me and I've got time
I've got a computer to check all this
the run shop was down on three minutes
and he figured out something else he saw
that after takes with the porn queen b3
look this is hanging and this bishop is
also liability that there's queen c6
with the idea takes takes and now
attacking this rook
so our white needs to take care about
this this means this bishop is not
really hanging so he figured this out
with which is really great in three
minutes so gallant needed to go here you
to cover this no other way and now queen
bee five and this is really interesting
this is some rhenium adequate
compensation for the piece amazingly the
computer gives gives a simple 0 0 0
because the out scientist it also
anticipates the coming news
yeah blacks got this c3 counter play and
look at those pieces they don't help
especially this monster pawn on h2 this
is not really contributing to to
anything here so this c3 is a big threat
Queen e2 was played to prevent that rook
e8 gaining a tempo Queen c2 and now c3
even shock now has got 10 moves left to
make and it's down on one minute
fifteen seconds but the big problem is
there's this threat and what is why it's
supposed to do about that it's it's
really scary for white and Gao phantom
looked at this for a couple of minutes
he was down to six minutes and then
decided to wrap this up to a draw and I
really understand that he didn't want to
see any more of this because of course
you are always tempted to somehow play
on time if the opponent is down so low
but the problem is that black is doing
black is able to make all those active
aggressive moves and it's much easier to
make those kind of forward moves than
playing some some tiny or difficult
defense if you try to play for Winnie
and you you really risk a lot the
computer to avoid the immediate draw
wants to play something like a four just
just to put it on the board it wants to
play something like this and even claims
a draw here with a later perpetual but
look at this is very scary for white it
seems that you can play Queen d1 and
then I don't know it simply it still
gives a draw but who wants to try that
it's very easy to to lose the game in
this way so I understand that gal Fanta
didn't want to to do anything of that he
just took on c3 and after Bishop c3 this
is a perpetual check Queen b3 Queen b3
and so on what can can lose a fee if he
wants to can play this move and then
there's the very strong Bishop d2 check
quite a flashy move but very strong King
takes is very easy and if the Queen
takes you can give this check Queen b1
rook e8 and black wins the house this is
even a direct mate yeah so a draw I
think I deserve deserved draw at the end
and the shame that even looks really
great concept here with with this
hanging knight on d5 wasn't round with
in this position instead of taking on d5
from this rook c2 idea but with three
minutes it's very difficult so again an
interesting round we had two really
exciting games or interesting games
yeah next round is tomorrow fifth round
with Carson playing even choke and we
see that one even shook is a very
unsteady player is playing interesting
chess so we can expect an interesting
game tomorrow let's hope that the magics
not going for some some dull Linus white
but trying to do something yeah thanks
for watching I'll be back tomorrow with
another video for round five bye